CABALLERO ATTENDEE DALLY DODD
DORADO EGGMAN GONZALEZ ROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO JONES
AIRED LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ IN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHIRLA VOTE.
PAN ARTIN TINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER AMBERG MY COW SKI
WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR HER TADO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR PORTIS SENATOR HER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY
WE CELEBRATE THE FEAST OF
JOSEPHINE BIKITA SHE IS
RECOGNIZED BY PEOPLE OF MANY
FAITHS AS A PATRON SAINT OF THE
ANTI TRAFFICKING MOVEMENT OF
THE CHILD IN SOUTHERN SUDAN SHE
WAS KIDNAPPED AND SOLD INTO
SLAVERY EVENTUALLY SHE BECAME A
NUN IN ITALY WHERE SHE WAS
KNOWN FOR HER HEALING PRESENCE.
SHE WAS OFFICIALLY DECLARED A
SAINT BY PAPA POPE JOHN PAUL
THE SECOND IN TWO THOUSAND-
MERCY. WITH THOSE DEPRIVED OF
FREEDOM AND DIGNITY FIND
CONSOLATION IN THE LIFE OF
DISCIPLINE BUT KIA. TRANSFORM
AND HEAL THE HEARTS OF THOSE
WHO INFLICT PAIN AND ANGUISH ON
OTHERS. GIVE HOPE AND
RESILIENCE TO ALL THOSE WORKING
TO READ TO KEEP ON GOING CRIME
OF SLAVERY AROUND THE WORLD AND
IN CALIFORNIA. THE WITH ALL OF
US IN OUR STRUGGLE FOR JUSTICE
LOVE AND PEACE AYMAN.
COLLEAGUES IF YOU COULD PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THIS IS. IT IS. SEVERAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE
SENATORS BATES GLAZER LA MON
AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD AFTERNOON REMOTE
SENATORS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
FEBRUARY EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. THREE THIRTY THREE
THIRTY ONE THREE THIRTY TO
THREE THIRTY THREE THREE THIRTY
FOUR THIRTY THIRTY FOUR FIVE
THREE THIRTY SIX THREE THIRTY
SEVEN AND SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FLE SENATE SECOND
READING ALL ITEM ONE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL. FIFTY
ONE. SENATOR WHAT WERE YOU
PRESENTED ARE PREPARED TO
PRESENT. PLEASE PROCEED YES MEN
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MEMBERS
REPRESENTS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE CONFIRMATION OF G.
C. COOPER HAS STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PRIOR TO
THIS APPOINTMENT MISS COOPER
WAS SERVING AS A SENIOR ADVISER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. SHE FIRST
JOINED IT D. D. H. CS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AS ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON THE TWENTY EIGHTH OF JANUARY
ON A FIVE OH VOTE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER WELCOME MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SENATOR PAN. HE MAY PRESIDENT
SENATORS LIKE TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
JC COOPER- TAKE- I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HER.
IN HER ROLES AT DCS IS CHAIR OF
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE HERE AS
WELL AS THE PAST CHAIR. OF THE-
BY JUST OF COMMITTEE ON. HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES- SHE HAS-
BEEN- NOT ONLY A DILIGENT
PUBLIC SERVANT BUT SOMEONE WHO
HAS HELPED- I THINK THERE'S A
VERY IMPORTANT- REFORMS IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM AND- CERTAINLY
I THINK WILL BE SOMEONE WHO
WILL SERVE AS WELL AS OUR-
MEDICAL DIRECTOR. SO I WOULD
ALSO URGE AND I VOTED FOR HER
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAT MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA ATKINS
I BAKER. I FOR JUST I BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO I CORTESE I DALLY
I DODD AYE DORADO I EGGMAN. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. BY HER
TADO BY JONES I LAYERED. I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE FIVE
MELINDA'S I MEN. HI NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH. I
PAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI I'M BURKE
FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI. I WIENER.
HI WELL. HI. FIVE THIRTY FOUR
NO ZERO THE IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS ITEM
THREE SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE A CONFIRMATION OF
MICHAEL ALLEN TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE APPEALS
BOARD MR ALLEN IS A FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IN ASSISTING
MAJORITY LEADER IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY HE
SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN. HE WAS
APPROVED ON A FIVE A VOTE BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR WILK MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR RUBIO. PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
MICHAEL ALLEN'S REPLACEMENT TO
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
APPEALS BOARD I HAVE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE AND HONOR OF KNOWING
HIM PERSONALLY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY MISTER ALLEN IS
EXTREMELY QUALIFIED FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT ESPECIALLY NOW THAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS FACE THE
TERRIBLE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
IN THE LABOR FORCE HIS MOTHER
WITH AN IMMIGRANT TO THIS
COUNTRY HE RATE- WHO WAS RAISED
BY A SINGLE MOTHER HE WORKED AS
A NURSE PUT HIMSELF THROUGH LAW
SCHOOL AND WAS A LABOR LEADER
HELPING RESOLVE LABOR DISPUTES
MR ALLEN UNDERSTANDS THE PLIGHT
OF OUR WORKING FAMILIES. AND
THESE TRYING TIMES HAS
EXPERIENCED WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO. MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. AND
HEARING THE MA'AM SO PLEASE THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA ATKINS
I BAKER. I FOR JUST. GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM AYE
CORTESE I DALLY. DODD FIVE
DRAWS I EGGMAN. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HUESO. I
HER TADO HI JONES. LAYERED I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
OCHO OF BOTH I PAN I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH. HI RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
FIVE AMBERG I AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER. I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE UP MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
PORGES. DALLY. GROVE JONES.
MELENDEZ NIELSEN. I TWENTY
EIGHT ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED IN THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SENATOR WILK THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORCE A CONFIRMATION OF
LARA CAN'T MONEY TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE APPEALS
BOARD PRIOR TO THIS ROLE MISS
CAN'T MONEY WAS AN ATTORNEY
SPECIALIZING IN IMMIGRATION LAW
SHE WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE OH
VOTE IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
THE TWENTY SEVENTH OF JANUARY
HI I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER
WELCOME NUMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR HERTZBERG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT A
PRESIDENT I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF INTERVIEWING OF THIS-
APPOINTEE AND- ALSO
INTERVIEWING BOTH PRIVATELY
YOUR RESUME AS WELL AS- YOUR
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY DON'T
SAY THIS VERY OFTEN BUT SHE'S
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPRESSIVE
THOROUGH THOUGHTFUL AW AND I
THINK SHE WILL BE A GREAT.
ADDITION CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT HER- CONFIRMATION THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING THEM
OUT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA ATKINS
I BAKER I FOR JUST. BRADFORD R.
I. CABALLERO I PROTECTING AYE
DOLLY. DODD I DRAWS I EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
FIVE HUESO. I HER TADO I JONES.
LAYERED I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ. MAN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. OTOBO FIVE PAN. FIVE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I AM BURKE I WACO SKI.
FIVE WIENER. FIVE WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA GORGEOUS. DALLY
GROWTH I. JONES MELENDEZ.
NIELSEN. FIVE THREE NINE NINE
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. SHE WAS A
PART OF. BEN PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR FRIDAY FRIDAY NOT
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE FRIDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GOOD WEEK MEMBERS.